l'objectif c'est justement ce n'est pas
de rester entre historiens spécialistes
entre psychiatre entre politologue
au contraire il s'agit de mettre
ensemble tous ces savoirs la de les
mutualiser de manière à ce que toute la
population puisse avoir accès à ces
informations qui sont les informations
importantes qui permettent d'aller plus
loin de ne pas hésiter à macérer dans
une espèce de souffrance d'une
l'amertume dans une rue sentiment au
contraire il s'agit de rebondir dans ce
livre c'est que il y à des informations
scientifiques qui nous permette de
l'avant bon espoir qu'on puisse en
sortir un jour ou l'autre
alors comment avez vous eu cette idée de
création de ce livre comment évolue
cette gestation
c'est à dire que jusqu'ici il y avait
des informations parcellaires et quand
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
des informations sur la transmission
génétique dessus sur l'adn des
traumatismes psychologiques de
génération en génération
je me suis dit c'est pas possible que un
traumatisme comme celui de l' esclavage
qui est largement sous-estimé qui est
largement banalisé
parce que les gens ne se rendent pas
compte du drame que ça a été et comment
l'esclave âge a bouleversé le monde ça a
été le moment c'est ce que dit
d'ailleurs maintenant les nouveaux
historiens
ça a été le basculement du monde
on en reparlera mais donc l'importance
de cette ligne de cet événement en
termes d' exactions de souffrance et de
déshumanisation n'a pas pu ne pas
laisser des traces
il donc ses traces on les retrouve pas
seulement bien sûr dans l'est dans la
caraïbe
bon on les retrouve aussi aux états unis
et aux états unis j'ai l'impression
encore que les traces sont plus marqués
plus forte plus présente aujourd'hui
dans tous les pays qui ont subi
l'esclavagé un taux de violence excessif
pourquoi parce qu'on ait fait le stage a
humilié il donc l'humiliation entraîne
une rébellion
une révolte est donc une violence
maintenant
maintenant que nous connaissons
maintenant que nous pouvons revisiter le
lieu de la souffrance que nous
connaissons mieux les l'histoire de
l'exclavage que nous apprenons qu'il y a
eu des révoltes et que les esclaves sont
restés ligne ils sont restés humains et
ont réussi justement grâce à cette
dignité à rester 10 être debout et bien
c'est grâce à s'y connaissent en cela
que nous pouvons désormais revisiter
l'histoire de l'exclavage sans ressentir
la morsure de la douleur la mort cieux
de l'amertume ou de l'aigreur ou du
ressentiment
si grâce à ses connaissances des
historiens mais grâce aussi au fait que
nous savons que le traumatisme
psychologique peut s'améliorer peut se
guérir